schluss mit schmuggel und schleuserei
stillstand für viele autofahrer an der
a4 bei görlitz und einer bundesstraße
der sächsischen gemeinde oder biz beide
orte liegen nahe der polnischen
beziehungsweise tschechischen grenze
grenzüberschreitende kriminalität ist
keine seltenheit
es war eine der grössten
kontrollaktionen der jüngsten zeit 240
polizisten der bereitschaftspolizei
sachsen 80 beamte der polizeidirektion
görlitz sowie beamte der bundespolizei
und des hauptzollamtes dresden waren im
einsatz
eine aktion der soko argus ziel der
sonderkommission aus ist die bekämpfung
der grenzüberschreitenden kriminalität
die kontrollen sind jedoch so angelegt
dass diese ganzheitlich durchgeführt
werden das heißt es werden von
verkehrsrechtlichen verstößen bis hin zu
auch den zollrechtlichen bestimmungen
durch die kollegen verklingen des zolls
geprüft bereits am dienstagabend gab es
eine ähnliche aktion dagegen den beamten
auf einer autobahn in sachsen
beispielsweise ein türkischer melonen
laster mit 31 illegalen migranten auf
der ladefläche ins netz und auch heute
waren die beamten erfolgreich unter
anderem dank der hervorragenden nase von
spürhund ethos ja dienst und ist heute
zur absuche eines pkws eingesetzt worden
und hat in einem vortrag ein rauch gerät
bzw
anhaftung von rio
also drogen gehören hier zum alltag und
wir fahren sehr viele einsätze
kontrolliert wurden autofahrer aus
großbritannien belgien rumänien und vor
allem aus polen
also wir haben schon die kontrollen
gesehen bei zittau und görlitz kasten
care hat sie für uns beobachtet was
haben sie denn noch so entdecken können
die beamten die zweibeinigen und die
vierbeinigen in den kontrollierten
fahrzeugen
ja hallo moritz also ich befinde mich
hier jetzt gerade an der bundesstraße b
178 m in oderwitz das liegt ca 30
kilometer entfernt von der polnischen
grenze und hier sind die beamten
besonders aktiv weil sie klein
transporter und lkw kontrollieren
bereits seit den morgenstunden hier hat
sich zum beispiel gezeigt dass eine
ganze menge zigarettenschmuggel zum
beispiel aufgetaucht ist also es gab ja
einen rumänen
der kam mit zwei großen beutel mit 600
paketen zigaretten hier ein musste
natürlich stand bei den beamten des
hauptzollamtes dresden ordentlich nach
zahlen und wie wichtig sind denn diese
kontrollen sozusagen in der grenzregion
für den zoll um halt ja illegalen
grenzverkehr und schmucke eindämmen zu
können
natürlich es gibt hier also seit
november vorigen jahres wurde extra die
sonderkommission gegründet die hier im
wahrsten sinne des wortes dann ein auge
drauf wird auf diese grenznahe
kriminalität und es geht ihnen besonders
darum eben die grenznahe kriminalität
einzudämmen auf der einen seite und auf
der anderen seite geht es ihnen auch
darum bei der bevölkerung ein
sicherheitsgefühl zu wahren das sei
ihnen ganz ganz wichtig denn es gibt ja
immer wieder probleme es hat sich zum
beispiel gezeigt dass als die grenzen
corona bedingt geschlossen worden
haben sich die kriminalitätswelle nahezu
halbiert so hat mir das zumindest ein
sprecher der polizeidirektion hier
in görlitz mitgeteilt und die grenzen
sind nun wieder auf und nun steigen auch
die kriminalitätszahlen wieder deshalb
heute diese groß angelegte
kontrollaktion an zwei verschiedenen
standorten heute früh war ich an der
autobahn a4 auf dem parkplatz löbauer
wasser und jetzt eben hier in oderwitz